by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on Senate bills
referred to this committee with the
potential for executive sessions to be
held throughout although it's Our
intention to have our executive session
at one o'clock today please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a the right
to no law
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
we do have one staff member who is
assisting us today and who is on the
conference call and that's Jennifer for
our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting will be done
by roll call vote
we're going to begin the meeting by
taking roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there's anyone in the room
with them during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
Mr clerk would you call the roll
ing Gordon I am here I'm in the lob 301
303 committee room with other members of
the committee representative McLean I'm
here uh president
the clerk is here in the committee rooms
with other members of the committee
representative rice
I'm here in the committee room with the
chair
[Music]
representative Alexander I'm here in the
room at the chair representative norter
here
he's in his Committee of a committee
uh representative green indicated that
he might be late arriving today because
he has a competing committee meeting
tonight
sorry about that
um I'm here in Temple with the dog kids
might come to get my car keys but that's
about it
representative Troyer
good morning I'm here in Belmont alone
representative Smith
uh good morning I'm in Durham
alone
good morning I'm alone in Westmoreland
representative Oregon
I am alone at home in Durham
representative
case
Merritt Island Florida and I'm here by
myself representative Kenny
good morning I'm here in Durham in my
apartment alone currently roommates may
be uh throughout the room throughout the
representative Macbeth
good morning I'm here present in my home
in Portsmouth New Hampshire alone
representative Paige good morning I am
in my home in Exeter alone
representative Simpson
good morning I'm here in Exeter alone
and my kids and spouse may be through at
some point during the day representative
Sylvia I'm here in the Legislative
the 19th president
chairman thank you Mr Claire
uh we're here this morning
and
I understand that there may be
amendments that we made to that today
and if you are intending to make an
amendment you should make that known at
I'd note that there was an amendment
that was sent around by representative
Birch specifically an amendment to add
on uh some language I reviewed that and
indicated that I found that non-germaine
and the only way uh and that's pursuant
to house rule 46b
and the only way that that can be heard
and included as an amendment is if
they're the committee were to decide to
hold a separate hearing on that
Amendment
and so uh if uh if representative Birch
wanted to move to hold a hearing I would
schedule that hearing for next week when
we're scheduled to exec Senate bill 96.
you're muted
uh thank you Mr chair and I first want
to express my appreciation for the heads
up uh from you on this issue uh it makes
life for everyone go a little bit
smoother uh when we know some of these
things in advance so I appreciate the
the courtesy extended to me and the
committee
on this uh if I understand correctly uh
with a vote of the committee uh we would
take this matter up
um in here in a public hearing a week
from now I uh have no objection to that
I would support this as a method of
moving forward I I would I don't know if
the it's necessary for me to move the
amendment now
uh if uh I see uh our clerk saying no uh
but uh nice looks like our chair is
saying no so I won't move the amendment
now
what what I think I think what you need
to do is have a motion to hold a hearing
on your Amendment uh all right and then
uh we can determine whether or not the
committee is in agreement with that all
right and ISO move that we have a public
hearing uh on Amendment one two four
four h
um I would indicate just briefly that
the reason I filed it in advance of this
hearing and not at the exact session uh
was to have a public hearing so I'm all
in favor of this motion passing and if
it does pass I have one question from
the chair and that is there are a number
of people lined up uh expecting to
testify today
uh in public hearing uh I don't know if
this passes whether it would be the
chair's position to take those people
today and still have the remainder in a
week or do it all in a week's time and
free up those today to leave if they
wish well I think uh first of all is
there a second to uh representative
Birch's motion
my second
I think I saw a hand from representative
Macbeth first so she'll second the
motion and to answer your question uh I
have the same concern that you have is
that people will testify to your
Amendment today and then we're going to
hold a hearing next week and then they
come back and testify all over again a
second time we really don't need to do
that so I guess what I I would say is if
people have made the effort to be here
today and want to testify on your
Amendment they should do so but not
expect to come back and testify next
week and give us the same testimony
again next week so I'll give them their
choice as to whether or not they want to
testify today or next week if that makes
sense
that only leaves me the remaining
questions then do do I have to put the
amendment on the table so to speak
for people to discuss
ion
yeah I I I think
before
I uh
I I don't think you need to do that I
think they can speak to the amendment uh
I think we all have a sense of what the
amendment is uh although I know you've
made some changes to what was uh 111. so
I think we're all set
thank you yes so Mr chairman Mike
I have some difficulties with this
we're required to in order to adopt the
non-germaine family we're required to
have separately noticed public here
that's correct so we'll we'll have to
have a hearing next week
no matter how much testimony we take for
that and I will
say that there may be a lot of people
who don't know about this amendment
who might want to testify
all right I have no way to know it but
it's just a normal course of action
that's why we notice me
so
yeah
yes representative rice I think that if
we
um have the people who want to testify
on this amendment testify next week and
get it all in one lump sum there'll be a
lot less repetitive testimony
um I think our questions we won't be
asking to duplicating questions I just
think it's better to keep it all
anybody else
I think uh representative Birch what I
what I've just heard is people would
prefer to have the testimony next week
as opposed to have people testify today
even though
I understand that some people may have
come today specifically to do so they
may not be available next week
I guess if they weren't going to be
available next week then I wouldn't want
to
prohibit them from giving their
testimony
all right thank you and I appreciate
everyone's uh consideration I as a
matter of of uh believe I I encourage
public participation in our uh
proceedings I I let people know as soon
as I heard from the chair that it was
possible that we would not be proceeding
with with testimony today so
um if it's a matter of rescheduling all
of them for next week
um I can live with that with the
understanding that if some of these
individuals cannot make it next week
they have a week to submit
um and their testimony in writing if
they wish
uh it's my intention to act on
Senate Bill 96 next week with with all
amendments so I don't think we would be
looking for an additional week but they
do have a week to test they do have a
week to submit their testimony this week
that's what I meant uh
if I wasn't clear
thank you
we do have a motion the motion is
whether or not to hold a hearing on the
amendment
and as proposed by
representative Burch and Mr clerk would
you call a role on that
on whether or not to hold the hearing on
Amendment one two four four eight
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes
Court folks know
representative Alexander no
representative Bryce no
representative Lerner no
representative green
you know he representative Kelly yes
foreign
ER
now
yes
representative yes representative Oregon
representative delrento yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes Mr chairman
no
so by about eight
voting eleven to eight uh I will arrange
for it to be in the calendar that will
hold the hearing on the amendment next
week
and that brings so again if you if you
are here today and on our teleconference
and your intention is to speak just to
representative Birch's Amendment uh you
should plan to testify next p week next
week if you are able to do so
and I'm going to call up we're going to
begin our hearing on Senate Bill 96 as
it was sent over to us from the Senate
and I'll call upon the prime sponsor
you could raise your hand if you're
there representative Bradley good
morning Mr chair good morning
uh good morning uh members of the
Judiciary Committee for the record Jeff
Bradley from Wolfeboro pleased to be
with you today as the sponsor of Senate
bill 96.
I was asked by then attorney general
McDonald
and then Governor's legal counsel John
fermella both of whom have
been elevated in positions
in December to file Senate Bill 96 as a
result of the unanimous recommendations
of the governor's liact Commission
uh Mr chairman as you know
a number of the recommendations of the
liac commission
are in the process of being implemented
uh through executive order at the
present time
what Senate Bill 96 seeks to do
is to put into law those
recommendations of the liac commission
that needed a change in law to implement
so not all of the 40 plus
recommendations of the liac commission
are included in Senate Bill 96 but many
of them are
this Bill had broad support in the
Senate there was some discussion about
the voluntary information
on driver's licenses which was turned
into a study committee but with the
exception of that one discussion in the
Senate it was adopted on a bipartisan
basis in fact the vote Mr chairman was
unanimous
I want to um at this point thank all of
the co-sponsors of this bill including a
member of your committee representative
Smith for um co-sponsoring it let me
just walk through the bill briefly
um the first section of the bill creates
the
um body worn in-camera fund to help
local law enforcement agencies purchase
body cameras another recommendation of
the liac commission
section two of the bill deals with the
retention of records that should be kept
for a 20-year period of time except for
the exceptions that are outlined in the
bill the third section of the bill Mr
chairman
um calls for any memorandum of
understanding between a police
chief and school resource officers to be
made available to the public as a public
document
sections four
five
four and five
deal with a body worn camera fund I
think increasingly in our state and
Nation we are realizing the body worn
cameras
are a very very good idea to understand
exactly what has happened in some of the
circumstances that we have seen
um in our state and in other states in
section five uh the sum of a dollar is
appropriated in this bill I think Mr
chairman as you know in House Bill 2
the house passed a one million dollar
appropriation
um for body worn cameras
um section six and seven deal with
delinquent delinquent children
and um the new section is the language
that about no person under 13 shall be
subject to proceedings
Section 8 as I mentioned in the opening
replaces
um the
voluntary inclusion of information on
race and ethnic
data on driver's licenses
there was a major concern in the senate
about even though it was voluntary in
nature if it ever became mandatory it
would be akin to racial profiling so the
Senate deemed it worthy of a study
committee to examine the issue further
lastly section 9 talks about
in the judicial system
judges and justices receiving implicit
bias training and racial profiling
training
so those are the sections of the bill
I just want to comment if I could Mr
chairman and
um it's not my place to
um talk about your procedures in the
house and I don't want this interpreted
as doing so however
as I think of where we are on May 11th
you would have a public hearing
on this bill next week on
the qualified immunity amendment that
the house previously defeated and then
presumably vote in the first week of
June the Senate would be in a very
difficult position Mr chairman of not
having had an opportunity to have a
public hearing
on an issue that
I think whether you agree with the
language in the amendment or don't agree
with the language in the amendment
senators are going to want to consider
that as they consider the bill
the inability to do that and have a
public Hearing in the Senate
would be extraordinarily problematic Mr
chairman so I'll leave it at that and
let that be part of your consideration
as you take the actions that you deem
necessary to take on Senate bill 96.
thank you
thank you are there any questions for
Senator Bradley
yes representative naughter thank you
um good morning Senator you mentioned
section nine
it's on page
three
uh Mr chairman I I had a hard time
hearing that question maybe you could
repeat it there was a question as to the
to section nine
at line 13. thank you
uh I think I think you are you all set
representative yeah I think the
question's been answered thank you okay
thank you
and are there any other questions for
um I'm looking at the bill and just
trying to match up the amended analysis
on the first page with the rest and I
can't seem to match it up is that a me
problem or is that um
a larger problem that people are having
I'm just paying attention to the bill
but I'm wondering if I should
try to square any of that language
with the parts of the bill that Senator
I think we're all having the same
problem and that uh the amended analysis
shows six parts but the bill itself
uh
chose 10 actually with the effective
date portion 10 parts so uh it's a bit
confusing Mr chairman if I might
um for instance six and seven the
section dealing with delinquent children
that's Roman 4 in the amended analysis
there are two sections there uh section
one
uh four and five deal with a body worn
camera fund
and
that is Roman three in the amended
analysis I believe that all of the
sections
are correctly noted in the amended
analysis
um but just if if you would just please
remember that in the amended analysis it
covers in a couple of those Provisions
that I just cited more than one section
foreign
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you Mr chairman
and
the next speaker would be uh
um thank you Mr chairman I was going to
be providing information on the proposed
amendment so I will hold off to next
week
thank you
Joseph uh
pobeki
[Laughter]
can you hear me uh Mr chairman we can
hear you fine
all right excellent good morning uh
chairman Gordon members of the committee
my name is Joe hobeki
and I'm the chief of police in Hollis
New Hampshire I'm also the first vice
president for the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
and I've been in law enforcement for a
little over 20 years and although I'm
not originally from the state of New
Hampshire I'm certainly proud to call
New Hampshire my home
um
so I registered today as neutral on this
bill because I anticipated that there
would be uh we would be speaking to the
amendment on qualified immunity so I'll
reserve my comments for that and I think
you probably uh
know how I stand on that portion of the
amendment but I will certainly be back
next week to testify in opposition to
that but I do support the current uh
Provisions within Senate Bill 96 I was
uh both honored and very fortunate to
serve on the legislative work group
for this bill with various other
stakeholders to develop language
relative to uh you know training for
judges body worn camera
systems juvenile delinquency hearings
memorandums of understanding for a
school resource officers and then data
collection relative to dermographics on
police citizen contacts
um although the bill before you is a A
variation of the uh the original
legislation as is is common uh I
certainly do support the language
contained within I did however uh wish
to mention that this amended version of
the bill is absent language uh relative
to collection of demographic information
with police and citizen encounters
um given the recommendation of the liac
commission from uh this past summer uh I
do feel as though this is an important
and appropriate piece within the bill
and although I understand the concerns
expressed by the Senate on adding race
and ethnicity to a person's driver's
license uh I still feel as though the
collection of such demographic uh
information
um uh is important and it also conforms
with leak recommendation
it is however uh important to note that
there are limitations when collecting
this data given the varying capability
as a police records Management systems
and for the sake of time uh I won't
speak to that but I'd be certainly
willing to discuss this in these issues
with members of the committee at a later
time if if it's deemed appropriate so in
closing I support the bill
and I continue to work with the various
stakeholders to ensure that New
Hampshire law enforcement continues to
meet the demands of policing in the 21st
century
while setting the highest standard for
other states to follow so I thank you
very much chairman Gordon members of the
committee for your time and
consideration be happy to answer any
questions you might have
yes representative McLean thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I just have a quick question
um because it is more a question of
familiarity on my part
um the memorandum of intent
um uh between uh the schools and the law
enforcement what typically is in that
just for my education purposes
um thank you for your question
representative there is a law contained
within that
um
a quick kind of
I guess uh Cliff Notes version of what's
contained with an rmou is you know it
sets provisions on the responsibility of
a school resource officer
um it can get as finite as stipulating
that they'll be provided with office
space what the expectations of their
service hours to the school enrolls and
responsibility within School discipline
and such are I'd be happy to share with
you and members of the committee a link
to our current mou which is right on our
website it's a public document for
everyone to see
for your review it's by no means you
know a template for other agencies or
other towns to follow but I think we're
certainly proud of that mou I I believe
it is it was used as a framework for the
model mou which is currently published
on the police standards and training
website
seen them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you Mr chairman
I I should have indicated at the
beginning of the hearing that on the
sign up sheets there were 121 people who
signed up in support of Senate Bill 96.
there were 12 people who signed up in
opposition
four people who signed up as neutral
the next person to testify would be uh
thank you Mr chairman can I be heard you
can oh great thank you thank you so much
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is yield Bissonnet I'm the legal
director for the ACLU of New Hampshire
we strongly support SB 96
and really want to Echo some of the
things that that chief o Becky just said
in his testimony this is really
consensus legislation where all
stakeholders got together and met for
months over last summer to discuss what
policies we could agree to as a state
that would help Foster trust between the
police and the communities they serve
and this included state and local law
enforcement police unions the NAACP the
ACLU and others and in the testimony
that I circulated to the committee
yesterday evening I footnoted the liact
commission report in that testimony and
I would certainly encourage folks in the
community to if they haven't already to
to take a look at that it's I think in
excess of 100 pages and really
was the product of hundreds of hours at
work
um among key stakeholders in the state
and I could tell you from the ACLU
perspective we were really proud to I've
been a part of that process and the
result of that really is what's in the
bill presented before you
um there's one issue that I want to
raise and it was it was addressed both
by chief o Becky and Senator Bradley and
that's with respect to the data
collection component we do support an
amendment to SB 96 I circulated that
proposed amendment to the committee
yesterday evening this amendment would
add back into the bill the language
recommended by the liac commission and
that was in the original bill that would
require the collection of racial data in
law enforcement stops of course the
inclusion of that information on the
driver's license is optional that's left
to the individual when they're filling
out the driver's license application and
this was as I said removed by the Senate
and we think this language is critical
and stakeholders and law enforcement
groups supported this policy as a way to
further Foster trust between the
community and law enforcement and we do
not necessarily in our view the aclu's
view see a need for a further study
Commission on this issue which is
reflected in the current bill I believe
it's section eight and that's because we
already studied it and then we have
commission studied this uh extensively
and I could say too that the police
Chiefs Association as well provided
tremendous leadership and feedback in
coming up with language that was
feasible and that language is reflected
in the amendment that I proposed last
night and with the collection of this
data we can learn whether we you know
have racial disparities in policing in
New Hampshire or whether we don't and if
we have this issue then we can work on
as a state taking proactive steps to
address it and I would also note that
many police departments actually in New
Hampshire actually already correct
collect this data under the Kalia
certification so we know that this is
feasible and as I said before the
language that's proposed in my memetus
language that was drafted not only by
the clu but with the help of uh and
feedback of the chiefs of police in the
AG's office to make sure that we're
doing this in a way that's feasible for
law enforcement who have to do this
um you know in the in the trenches of
the system and we really do want to make
sure that this is something that's
practical and workable and I'm very
confident that the language that we came
up with and that's reflected in our
Amendment uh accomplishes that and so
with that I'll conclude my testimony
thank you so much for the committee's
time and I'd be happy to take questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr chairman
we have here representative Mike bordes
if you're there you should raise your
come see him
uh
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me we
can hear you fine
excellent thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Will Stewart
I'm the executive director of stay work
play New Hampshire which is a Statewide
nonprofit whose mission is to attract
and retain more young people here in the
granite state and I'm here today to
speak in favor of Senate Bill 96.
attracting and retaining more young
people is critical to the future of New
Hampshire we are as you may know the
second oldest state in the country with
one of the lowest unemployment rates and
on top of this we're the number one
exporter of high school graduates
seeking a four-year degree with 62
percent of these young people leaving
the state every year some of them come
back but a lot of them don't
in short New Hampshire needs all the
people we can get in general and all the
young people we can get in particular
our businesses need workers and
customers our towns need volunteer board
members and our non-profits churches and
Civic clubs all need volunteers to
accomplish their vital missions without
which our communities just can't
function
so about three years ago State work play
commissioned a survey to collect data on
why young people stay in and might leave
New Hampshire and one of the reasons uh
we found that young people might leave
is due to our state's lack of diversity
we heard this over and over again also
last fall and winter as we talked to
young people in nine locations across
the state as part of our policy and pint
series and indeed New Hampshire's lack
of diversity was a top three reason
cited for young people potentially
leaving the state
so as a result of these findings
increasing diversity equity and
inclusion here in New Hampshire has
become a policy priority for statework
play and it's for this reason that we
support SB 96 and bipartisan bill that
seeks to increase trust in the judicial
system as a whole and with law
enforcement in particular and both of
these are necessary if we want to
attract and retain more people of color
so thank you for your attention and for
your consideration in supporting Senate
bill 96.
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for Mr Stewart all right
so
I is it you're assertion that by just
collecting this data
somehow that's going to attract more
people of color into our state is that
what you're saying
well I'm saying that uh you know I think
the recommendations in this bill you
know aim to again to increase trust uh
in law enforcement and the judicial
system you know as a whole it's it's one
piece of uh of doing that and I think
that increasing trust again in the
judicial system and law enforcement in
particular that is is key to uh you know
not just attraction but uh you know
perhaps more the retention of um of
yes representative Alexander um thank
you Mr chair thank you uh Mr Stewart for
taking that question
um there may be proposed amendment or
there's going to be a public next week
um the statework plan on testifying or
what would be stay replaced position on
that
with regard to the qualified immunity
Amendment yes sir
uh at present uh we do not have an
opinion on that as our our board of
directors has not uh and our advocacy
committee have not discussed that uh
particular piece uh at present so uh no
uh no opinion right now
thank you May and I ask a point of order
of the chair yes you may
um is it uh going to be allowed to ask
questions because I certainly would have
asked the sponsor the bill some
questions about uh what he said on
qualified immunity
I think our intention was that we
wouldn't get into uh your Amendment
today so I apologize for the pity thank
you
representative Smith
how's that
and did you have another question
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
there we go sir can you hear me we can
hear you fine thank you very much uh
good morning Mr chairman and fellow
committee members uh my name is Mark
Morrison and I am the President of the
New Hampshire Police Association I've
been in law enforcement in New Hampshire
for over 22 years and uh I was proud to
be selected to serve on Governors in new
zliac Commission
the work this commission accomplished
was something that only happened because
of the dedication of those involved and
the ability to actually listen and not
talk at one another New Hampshire has
set the bar for other states and that we
came together collectively to discuss
and and listen
we came up with recommendations that
have been acted on in totality
you know all 48 recommendations have
been acted on this lets this legislation
actually represents some of those
recommendations
um
to include you know the totality of
those 48.
I had planned to testify simply in
support of this legislation today and
only highlight how this type of
legislation can be accomplished in New
Hampshire when folks demonstrate
cooperation
teamwork and compromise
we now have grave concerns about any
amendments that may be added to the
legislation at the last minute that
could really jeopardize the success of
this or any other legislation the
recommendations found in this bill are
are really too valuable to risk the
failure of the entire bill
um and I'll reserve my right to testify
in the amendment next week of course
um and I'll simply say that the New
Hampshire Police Association supports
the recommendations put forward from
leac and supports this legislation
to briefly speak to attorney bissonnet's
testimony you know we also agree that
data collection is very important and I
believe the reason there is support for
data collection from New Hampshire law
enforcement is because we do not have a
problem with disparaging treatment of
minorities in our statistics can be used
to demonstrate that
uh New Hampshire law enforcement really
Prides itself in doing a good job here
for the citizens of the state
um and any opportunity we have to
demonstrate that we obviously are for
so I won't take up any more of your time
and I will simply say in this current
form uh we are in support of SB 96
um I hope that doesn't change
but other than that I will gladly take
any questions you have thank you very
much representative McLean thank you Mr
chairman
um this this might have been a question
for for Senator Bradley because it flew
through a lot of the bill broadly
speaking but by understanding that the
initial react recommendations had the
Gathering of the data but then it went
to a study committee in the modified
version of the Senate bill
um are you aware of the decision making
what were the concerns that drove it in
that direction
um as I said Senator Bradley may have
mentioned the reasoning behind it by the
do you just refreshed me on why that was
it would be helpful
I I caught most of that
um I apologize it was a little hard to
hear but did you did you say there were
you're you're asking about
um mistakes made in in a recommendation
no no um it's my understanding that the
original liac recommendations had the
Gathering of this data but that the
Senate amended it to go to a study
committee and so this may have been a
question for Senator Bradley but are you
aware of the concerns that were raised
that moved the Senate to take it and put
it into a study committee as opposed to
leaving it in in its original
recommended form
well I certainly think that that would
be a question for Senator Bradley
um representative McLean I'll try to
answer at least in part and and I think
even the study committee is still uh
conceptually in support of the
recommendation it wasn't a
um denial of of the recommendation and I
think uh there was some you know
important topics brought up that
you know maybe need to be
spoken of a little bit more in depth
more in detail but for the most part the
um our support for that recommendation
is
is pretty basic you know we we support
the ability
um you know of law enforcement to to
present you know statistical data uh but
how that gets there
um you know certainly
you know the Senate has has some
concerns they'd like to address so I I
won't speak to their process simply the
our support for that recommendation
thank you for your testimony today thank
you have a good day
this person is Ani Malachi or Malachi
Malachi
if you're there you need to raise your
hand
know
I do not see a Human Rights Commission
right yes good morning uh this is Ani
Malachi can you hear me
we can we can hear great thank you very
much
um and good morning to the Judiciary
Committee I appreciate the opportunity
to continue to provide full-throated
testimony for SB 96
um as it stands currently with no
additional amendments and I will also
Echo the statements made by previous
participants who have given very
supportive testimony over a wide range
of topics relative to the contents of
sb96 there are two small disappointments
which is the removing of the collection
of data and moving that to a study
committee I think
um
attorney Bissonnet so eloquently stated
that
um the entire Lee act commission was a
study committee of sorts and we put in
the work and the hours listened to
testimony discussed debated and work
together cohesively to create the
recommendation to enhance the data
collection that law enforcement is
already doing to allow them to do it
more accurately at current my
understanding is there are there are
times where they have to guess and with
our beautiful Multicultural Society that
we live in I would I would hate to think
that someone who's not me has to guess
who I am and put that down in in their
data collection without having a
conversation with me about it or if I'm
upset and they have a conversation with
me and I withhold that information then
who I am is not reflected in the in the
information that's collected we which
therefore means that the data is
incorrect so whatever we're looking at
has holes in it already
the other sadness was the removal of the
recommendation that judges receive bias
training and removed it to a suggestion
um I think if you're going to make sure
that one side of the law enforcement
equation has a variety of trainings the
other side needs to have the exact same
training and not a suggestion but a
strong recommendation so that everyone
has the exact same information and is
moving through as as individuals move
through the through law enforcement and
through the justice system they are
receiving the same Equitable treatment
if there are issues then those issues
can be spotlighted and handled so
outside of that
I don't have anything further to add I
thank you for allowing me this time to
speak I will certainly sign up to speak
next week relative to the uh the
amendment that's being put forth and
with that I would conclude my testimony
and I appreciate any questions that any
of the representatives may have for me
and I thank you very much
yes representative otter
um
yes thank you very very much for the
question representative so and I in in
my uh fervor to give my testimony I
neglected to State although my day job
which I've come to you before uh come
before you before my day job excuse me
is the executive director of The Human
Rights Commission I was appointed as a
commissioner one of 14 for the liact
commission now to answer your question
Lee act stands for it's the governor's
law enforcement
in accountability community and
thank you
my pleasure any other questions for Miss
America
see none thank you thank you for your
testimony today thank you very much and
you all have an amazing day thank you
thank you
and
Mr Conley if you're there you need to
see no hands
um
both of these will be here next week
okay
yeah hi this is Brandon delposo I'll be
uh speaking next week if that's okay
with you thank you for calling on me
that's fine thank you
if you're there you need to raise your
hand
yeah it should be there next week
okay
and that
is the list of people who pre-registered
to speak today is there anyone else who
would like to speak I see Matthew
Broadhead has a hand up Matthew
Broadhead
hi good morning chairman can you hear me
we can hear you fine
thank you my name is Matthew Brodhead
I'm a senior Assistant Attorney General
I'm the bureau chief here at the
Attorney General's Office of the
transportation and construction Bureau
and uh included in my client profile
would be the department of safety
including the division of State Police I
was honored to
uh the kind of pointed uh appointed as
the the point person by then attorney
general Gordon McDonald uh to help reach
out to community stakeholders to draft
this legislation
um and uh I do appear today on behalf of
the current attorney General John pomela
in full support of this legislation
um by way of background for those
members who don't know
um after the murder of George Floyd the
governor in June of 2020 had established
the commission of law enforcement
accountability community and
to develop recommendations for reforms
necessary to enhance transparency
accountability and community relations
with law enforcement in August the
commission issued as was said before 448
recommendations all of them have been
begun to be implemented many have been
completed as we stand here today there
were several items that required
legislation and this bill Senate Bill 96
is an Omnibus Bill that contains all of
the recommendations except for two that
required legislation
um
I I was going to say many things that I
think have already been said so I for I
don't want to be repetitive but what I
will say is that the commission and the
governor and the Attorney General all
believe
that the more transparency there is in
accomplishes many of those
um accomplishes that goal
um and
um and it makes much needed reforms to
our juvenile law we can't uh overstate
the the impact that this has and it is a
consensus bill I encourage the committee
to keep it a consensus bill
um and uh that's all I have I'm happy to
are there any questions for uh attorney
Brian
yes representative McLean yeah uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so just to follow up a little
bit on the Gathering of the racial data
um as the doj uh Point person in
drafting the legislation I'm just trying
to understand the concern that drove it
from you know straightforward Gathering
of data into the study commission if you
have any insight into what those are
um I don't have I I only have
um kind of third hand information on it
so I I don't feel comfortable uh calling
out you know with with authority what
the exact concerns were I will say that
Senator Carson had some concerns about
it
um
I I I had heard that
um there's a possibility that
um just even a simple function of
placing
um
the racial information on the driver's
license itself there's not physically
space that would permit it as it's
currently constituted and and to also
meet national standards for driver
licensing so I think that was one of the
issues that was raised there might have
been other concerns uh that were raised
as well
um so you know although we we certainly
support the original bill that was
introduced
um we we also uh you know support
further study uh if that's necessary
just so that we can get it right
um and and I don't see that the The
Establishment or our offices and see the
establishment of the study committee
um as anything other than just punting
to next legislative session
um and and we will continue to work on
the necessary reforms
um but certainly either way if the
committee were to add it back in we
would support it
um if the committee were to pass this
the bill as currently constituted we
would support that as well
representative Smith
yes thank you very much and thank you
for taking my question I'm a little
puzzled
um I understand that you're in a
somewhat delicate position
um not wanting to
um come out by saying anything that
indicates that you do not agree with
what the Senate did but
um if you were not in the legislative
environment but in a court and you were
asked do you support the language that
the was in the original bill
um what would your answer be
a hundred percent yes we support the
original bill thank you very much I
any other questions
sure yes
representative Sylvia thank you Mr
chairman thank you attorney broadhead
for taking my question
um with regard to uh the legislature
giving instruction to the court for uh
training uh do you see any concerns with
separation powers
I do I do I think that that was raised
uh by
um Richard head in the Senate and um we
had it supported
um the to accommodate the judiciary's
position to uh withdraw that original
language and replace it with the
suggested language part of the issue
with the original language was that
um it said it was written in a way that
um if I recall correctly
um that that it was ordering the Chief
Justice to issue rules or regulations uh
to require training and that's just not
practically speaking
um how they uh how they promulgate
training
um and they don't do it by rule making
and so uh the Judiciary uh has uh
testified in the Senate that they have
already adopted an annual training
um for implicit bias they've already
trained their judges on it and they they
plan to do that on an annual basis
um I believe but if Richard head is
still on I defer to him on specifically
you also
representative Smith
thank you again Mr chairman
um and thank you again for taking what
is basically the same question and that
is do uh does
um the Office of the Attorney General
support the language which is in uh this
bill now
we do we do thank you it was a
accommodation to the Judiciary which I
think was appropriate
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you all
thank you chairman Gordon and members of
the committee my name is Ken Norton I'm
the executive director of Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness and
um I was honored to be a part of the
liac commission I want to thank Senator
Bradley and all the sponsors of this
bill
um the work of the as you've heard the
work of the of the commission was
intense and involved a lot of compromise
and listening and uh I want to State my
full endorsement for the bill as written
and the recommendations that has written
an opposition to any amendments and in
the interest of time I won't repeat what
others have said
um thank you for your consideration and
I'm open to any questions
any questions for Mr Norton yes
representative Smith
thank you again so Mr Norton are you
then saying that you would oppose an
amendment which puts back into the bill
the language that Lee act had requested
and that was removed by the Senate
um uh and in which the Senate converted
to a study committee very specific
recommendation that Lee act had
uh thank you for your for that
clarification representative Smith no I
I support the the bill as it was
originally written um as you've
previously heard there was a lot of
discussion about uh and compromise in
the in the commission relative to that
uh specific recommendation and so I
would support an amendment to restore
that to the bill
yeah
thank you
thank you for your testimony
is uh there anyone else who wishes to
I see no hands
and so we'll conclude the hearing on
I believe that that concludes our
morning business we are scheduled for an
executive session at one o'clock today
and we will see unless there's other
concerns or business to do
I'm 43. well just we'll do that this
afternoon okay
foreign
good afternoon to our Union Leader cover
boy well actually I didn't have your
picture but
uh keep in mind we are being recorded
yes
foreign
okay we'll call this meeting of the
looks like we have everyone here with
the exception
Americans
but uh I guess we're beginner we'll
begin our discussion with Senate bill
so I will move
so
representative Sylvia moved out to pass
and with an amendment and you have an
amendment to offer
seconded by representative rice
and you want to address your Amendment
all right so um
1386h
relaxation
Amendment absolutely so this removes the
a third part with the study committee is
obviously a much better way to go
to
implement it with such a radical change
without a real
thank you
opportunity to discuss
changes
it's a little fast there's a lot we put
into 91a
lots of work
over the years we've fine-tunes and I do
when I hate to make sure that we have
good opportunity for the folks to
get information and also information for
non-public sessions while
provides a lot of opportunity for remote
access for the public
and the body I think that the more
serious concern is
from what I've been involved in tend to
lack
the real
communication that is necessary for
instance yesterday there was a press
conference that I attended on a certain
bipartisan in nature but uh
at the press conference uh believe it or
not you know there's Republicans
Democrats benetary
and some of the folks who actually
testified on this bill last week
and we actually had an opportunity to
talk
and
remotely do not get the same kind of
communication as you do in person
there's a lot missing there's facial
expressions even facial expressions that
are hidden behind mass at least if
you're face-to-face
get a better idea
the contemporaneous matter is really
lost in these things it's not
contemporaneous if two people start
talking over Zoom or whatever electronic
method
it just clashes because they're not
really it's not a duplex system so if I
started saying something out of water
and perhaps the chairman was not here
with us
uh he might be able to say something but
if I'm speaking loudly
that's going to shut him down
so there's a lot of problems that come
with remote meetings
that really need a much deeper study and
I think that removing part one and
hanging on to part three will give us
the time to really dig into it deeply
and make sure that we do it right the
first time and I'll have to come back
and fix it again later it's part one and
two you mean yes
so part three it so the bill analysis
has
the pieces
misorders so ignore the bill analysis so
part two in this is actually the
violation of privacy and patient privacy
so part one is the part that has to do
with implementing a remote session
part three is study committees
development to that so I think the study
committee is good but the implementation
it's it's just a little too soon to do
that and and we need to do it right and
I don't want to do it
[Music]
okay representative Birch
uh yes I do and thank you Mr chair and
it's actually it's a it's a question to
the sponsor of the amendment because I'm
a bit puzzled by the argument and
correct me if I'm wrong but it's my
understanding first of all that this is
permissive
that let's say if my local select board
wants to utilize these Provisions in
West Milan they would be able to but
um and thus it's not the the uh the
Supreme legislature often conquered
making this decision it could be well
local bodies and am I correct that you
are opposed to that
I am opposed to
uh
implementing those messages stated in
part one I think it's it's not
as well thought out as we would like it
and just one final follow-up if I could
um see no objection uh you suggest that
we need to study it more haven't we been
laboratory animals ourselves uh for a
considerable period of time uh far more
than a study committee normally devotes
to a topic so haven't we been the study
committee uh we in the legislature is
there really need to do more of what we
already know we may be in favor we may
be opposed but it's not the subject
matter that we're unfamiliar with
also I would say that the experiment has
gone
somewhat badly in some sections it's
certainly good for the public that wants
to view from their home but as far as
communicating between
committee members it's terrible so yes I
do believe that we need to study a way
that we can do this even even prior to
the this emergency when we had uh let's
say counseling delegation meetings and
we have one person call in because they
are not able to attend uh even then I
opposed because it's
it does not give you the equal footing
with your remote try and call in and
make a point you are at a disadvantage
so I I think people said it really needs
a much
more considerations
thank you
representative Horrigan
um yes well one concern is
thank you very much Mr chair one concern
and with Sylvia is talking about um you
know being able to communicate
informally with the uh committee members
and actually that's true but the 91a law
is written is trying to restrict that
sort of thing as much as possible at
least
expect the ideally
if everybody did it the way it's
intended there would never be any uh
private Communications at least between
members of the body at all or even
thinking about even obviously that isn't
100 uh doable so I think um
that sort of flies a little bit in like
what the 91a which is trying to
formalize body showed everything there
their liberations are as much as
possible totally you know on in public
and certainly um the hybrid meetings
first of all there's an automatic
recording capability built into it so
now there's a uh contemporaries
recording of everything that's said at
every meeting which uh I think is a
and generally certainly good thing in
the house where like it was impossible
even to all you had were like
handwritten notes by the clerk so like
it was even if you're at the meeting
sometimes it's hard to figure out what
it actually transpired so I think
um so that's a good thing there's also a
less scope for uh
for certain types of issues there's less
scope for intimidation like um with uh
bills involving guns there's always lots
of people coming
open carrying their guns or uh
and uh intimidates some people who are
sometimes refrigerated weapons people
who feared weapons although I'm not sure
why carrying weapons is irrational so
that puts certain types of debate on a
more uh
more more equal footing like it went to
a second amendment or gun Bill yesterday
and you know the uh people had the guns
and people didn't you couldn't tell who
was who because we're all sitting at
home our little rectangles I think
that's uh that was beneficial for that
debate so I I think uh
finally the main thing which maybe is
all I need to say is this has been
extremely popular with the public think
of
participation in meeting you know both
legislative hearings and uh you know
town you know Town meetings and County
meetings it's gone up a lot so it's kind
of um you know it's people uh people
find some more
area you can find us some more there are
technical diffuse but I think in general
people find this to be a more congenial
way to interact with their government
than the old way of doing it so um I
think we should uh I think we should
keep some of these innovations that
we're forced to make in place so um
that's um so I think uh I think this is
a bad amendment I think part one is part
one is good as it is um you know it
certainly doesn't need to be eliminated
so thanks
representative McLean uh yeah thank you
Mr chair I definitely think that you
know remote access does have a place in
the future I mean if we look at the
local level I'm often seen large groups
kind of dominate the discussion and the
increased access may be beneficial you
know to individual citizens in the town
and help level the playing field I think
that's the good but we also have to take
into account the bad and um some of the
bad that we've witnessed number one is
we have seen in this legislature
um I think luckily not in this committee
but in many other committees I've seen
Decor really go away and in many cases
watching these committee hearings not
like watching the committee here it's
like watching Twitter and I think the
one thing that has kept it from being
Twitter plus is that many members of the
committee have formed these
relationships these in-person
relationships so if it's through a
thought experiment where you move
yourselves out five ten years in the
future where this legislature has turned
over and we don't have those
relationships what will be the decorum
like in that case
um also as representative Sylvia
mentioned if you look at economy
delegation level I'm in the Hillsborough
County delegation which is admittedly
the largest delegation but those
meetings remotely in my opinion were
apps absolutely unworkable former
representative Kermit Williams who is
awesome in his best he was a real leader
but he was just completely overwhelmed
by this this mode of doing things so
there are places where it works and
there are places where it don't work if
it doesn't work I'm sorry the problem is
you know to representative purchase
Point while it is only permissive
um I think inertia if we just let this
thing go straight out of the state of
emergency inertia is going to keep that
going in One Direction and we really
strongly run the risk of carrying the
bad in with the good and so what the
break does what the stop when the state
emergency ends is it puts a break on
things and prevents that inertia from
happening and gives pause to allow the
study committee to understand fully
[Music]
but we need the pause just because we
need to break the inertia in right
position so I think this is a good
amendment to not be supportive
representative wolper thank you Mr
chairman
so I'd like to start with the idea of
participation
and I think we all applaud to vastly
increased public participation
and in everything that's been going on
whether it's a planning board meeting in
the town of Stratford or its attendance
at these committee hearings that's all
wonderful
it also doesn't require a change in the
law
any board or committee can allow can
implement
remote participation by the public
whenever they feel like it because you
know 91a does not say you can't do that
91 is there to increase transparency and
be welcoming of that
this is only about
the boards and committees meeting in
person
and
along with what representative Sylvia
began with
the fact that that that's
opportunity to not be gathered in person
has been relegated to only emergencies
in 91a to me should carry a lot of
weight that was not just furiously
thrown in that's been talked about and
talked over time and again just in my
time on this committee and it predates
when I got here
so so there's that but see I don't see
any great the benefits of public
participation are available whether we
do this or not
I've heard
of committee members who were denied
access remote access to their own not in
the house
it's not
have been denied remote access to the
board upon which they said they could
get in
but the person running the control of
meeting wouldn't let them speak
just like that
I don't know how widespread that is it
doesn't have to be very widespread
before it's a really big problem
uh I've heard other people talking about
other kinds of problems
and I just really think that this is
such a big deal because if we go this
way we can be pretty confident that our
executive the board meetings will be
like our executive session is today
when we have half the people here
and the other half are not
this would be bad this would be bad
trucks select boards and school boards
and I don't care how many who they are
and I recognize that there are a lot of
uh committees and Boards Commissions in
our state you know
geographically widespread and want to be
able to do this I do appreciate that but
before we just throw the door open
I think we have to be a lot more
reflective about it and I think the
study committee is the way to get that
reflection so I'll be supporting the
amendment
yeah
ribs and Horgan did you still have your
hand up do you want to speak again oh
um what I would just say they're talking
about being like uh Twitter plus some I
think there's been misbehavior and uh
silly things happening in the in
committee house committee meetings all
along it's just now
now there's like a camera trained on and
everybody can see it so I don't think uh
I don't think I don't think we're
necessarily behaving any better or worse
than we do probably a little better
because uh that's you know they're uh
where more eyes uh watching us I think
um I think from that that's not really
that particular argument against it like
doesn't hold much water for me are
certainly you know the people have a
right
I think it's useful for us to see what
we're
see what we're up to but I haven't seen
you know there's been some embarrassing
meetings on Zoom but there are
embarrassing meetings back uh before
we're on Zoom it's just nobody who
wasn't in the room unless there's a
camera an official camera pointed at the
room uh ever saw it and now people see
it but I think so that's that part of it
uh that part of I think it's good that I
think it's probably good that everything
that we're being recorded So
even though I tend to say funny things
sometimes so
that's just all I had to say about that
so thank you representative Simpson
thank you Mr chair
um I wanted to say I'm voting against
this amendment um because of how many
members of bodies and of the public that
I heard that have really appreciated
this uh option but I also wanted to say
that um we heard from the Senate that in
their compromise part of what they did
was Institute a sunset Clause so that if
after the study committee met there
wasn't um agreement that this should go
forward because of any issues that um
seem too pervasive
um it would automatically Sunset so I
just wanted to remind uh other
colleagues who might be concerned about
that
thank you
and I just wanted to
[Music]
I will be voting against this amendment
thank you
if not we have a motion the motion is on
Amendment
1386 h
which would remove the first part of the
bill
of Senate bill 95.
and if there is no other discussion no
other questions then Mr clerkin could
call the role
our amendment
1386h to Senate Bill 95 representative
McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes court votes
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes representative
representative breed yes
representative Kelly yes
representative daughter yes
yes
thank you representative Smith
uh no
representative Burke no
representative Oregon no
Representative no
representative Jews oh
representative Kenny no representative
Wayne Lee no
representative Michelle
no
representative page no
representative Simpson no Mr chairman
yes
[Music]
adopted Amendment 1386 h
representative Soviet you said you had
another amendment yes Mr chair and I
move
seconded by representative naughter
I want to address your Amendment
yes indeed so uh
this amendment
uh removes part two of USB 95
. this is a part on invasions of privacy
uh
so sometimes uh the remote readings
which I attended at home last week
occasionally missed some testimony but I
don't recall much testimony on this
section of the bill
s
but
there's little doubt
that those who are found guilty of
those crimes
Reserve their punishment and a
misdemeanor allows sentencing of up to a
year for these accounts charged
thank you testimony to the number of
cases and the extent of full year terms
sentenced to
it's unlikely
the first offense
brings a full year in jail
therefore we currently have a graduated
so by increasing the crime to a felony
we stand to suffer from consequences
which may not have been contemplated
first a felony charge will bring a much
stronger defense with Associated costs
to courts and possibly extending the
also there's a higher likelihood of a
jury trial once again impacting the
victim
there's a possibility a hope CD deal
which might disguise
the acts that the perpetrator committed
that lead to a different
Prime
also if the offender is sentenced to
State Prison
they are likely
not to return to the streets as reformed
people they're more likely to perhaps
pick up
lastly our constitution tells us in part
first article 18 I quote
all penalties
ought to be proportioned to the nature
of the offense
no wise legislature will affix the same
punishment
so the crimes of theft forgery and the
like
who stay due to those of murder and
treason
where the same undistinguishing severity
is exerted against all offenses
the people are alleged to forget a real
distinction in the crimes themselves
and to commit the most flagrant
with as little compunction as they do
the lightest defense
the city where he's in the multitude of
sanctuary flaws
is both in politic and unjust
the true design of all punishment being
to reform not exterminate mankind
so for each reason I ask you to support
yeah people definitely want me to want
having to mute buttons want to read
again in person but um
um representative Sylvia could you just
brief us on what this is just for one
particular crime in RSA 644.9 so could
you help a little bit more
about that and also can you clarify that
the May
be May rather than shout that say may
rather than shell so that it
so as I understand it it would be at the
prosecutor's discretion whether or not
too late hit the person with a felony
charge but the main thing is did you
tell us like what specific thing is 6449
is
so the
um I'm a little bit shaky on the
question that it's not coming through
the room very well but the crime is
invasion of privacy and basically this
is peeping Toms and people who put up
videos to balance in places where they
ought not to or take pictures uh in
bathrooms restrooms locker rooms
um those sort of things and currently
those are misdemeanors and this bill
would have a second or consequent uh
conviction
[Music]
um as a felony B which would be a
thank you
comments
I'm sorry can you say the number of the
amendment again when I when I had look
at that Amendment I'm not seeing this
language
thank you
I sent those out yesterday that uh
like 6 44 pm
I got it
I
can I ask a follow-up
when I um when I pull up 1361 from
yesterday I see that it deletes part two
yes you may be confused by the Amendment
so the actual bill section two is
if you read the text of the bill
the text of the bill is different than
representative
chair and uh representative Sylvia I
just want to be clear on this because
tell you the truth I was a victim of a
um
violation of privacy and it's not a fun
thing to happen and are you saying that
if we were to Omit this just so unclear
that would mean that these people can
just keep doing this and having
misdemeanors various verses actually
seriously being punished for the crimes
they're committing
so the the current punishment is up to a
year in the county jail for each offense
any other questions or comments
yes representative otter thank you and I
want to be here what you had to say
um so I think my question was about
answered too so it's more like a blood
pressure in the car like this is
different from Excellence actually
oh yeah this is definitely not right
foreign
this is this is invasion of privacy it's
not anything there's no physical contact
in this at all
so this is purely taking pictures video
representative thank you thank you
chairman I think that's an important
distinction that that you raised with
your question representative this is not
a violent part
IES are typically violent crimes things
like murder sexual assault kidnapped
it's typically physically violent things
not always but typically
as representative so relatively
Expressway and you're in jail it's not a
representative representative De Lorenzo
I have a question for them from
representative Sylvia you know during
sponsor some questions about
uh a person being convicted of this type
of crime
um having to register for the sex
offender registry and he didn't really
have an answer for me so
um
representative Sylvia do you think that
perhaps
SB 95 was drawn up hastily and
the elements the elements of this bill
don't
need more thought and don't naturally
um intersect with the current criminal
code
I guess you make a good point
if if we were talking about something
and I don't believe that these crimes
get somebody into the sex offender
registry I'm not I'm not an expert there
and perhaps they should but that would
be a different build than this bill this
any other questions or comments
representative Chase I saw your hand up
there for a minute do you have anything
else you'd like to say
oh well it was more of a a comment that
um the people that in my my opinion in
in my experience that do this they don't
stop and it will escalate and it goes on
for years and I think that we should be
putting them into jail for the year if
that's what our law is stating and um
possibly as you said it would be a
different bill but maybe after you know
two or three times that this gets put in
into the sexual register because it does
it doesn't stop with the pictures I'm
just telling you firsthand but thank you
I just needed to say that thank you
thank you
any other questions or comments
on Amendment 1361 H to Senate Bill 95
representative McLean yes representative
Sylvia yes court votes yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes representative
murder yes representative breed yes
representative Kelly yes
representative daughter yes
representative Smith
yes
representative Burke
representative Oregon
no
representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase oh
representative Kenny
yes
representative Langley
no
representative
representative Paige no
representative Simpson
no
Mr chairman yes I have it at 15 and you
firmative six in the negative
and
we're now open to further Amendment are
they have a promotion made by
representative Sylvia
to
any further discussion on the amendment
on the motion sometimes yeah the
much 1386.
1386 it was 11 to 10. thank you
foreign
representative Alexander yes
representative price yes
representative yes representative green
yes representative Kelly yes
representative and honor yes
representative trottier
yes
representative Smith yes
representative Burge
now
there's no
no no no
representative Morgan no
representative Utah
no
representative Chase no
representative Kenny no
representative Langley no
Representative no
representative page no
representative Simpson
no
Mr chairman yes either there's 12 in the
12 9 you uh We've made the
recommendation of off to pass as amended
on the Senate bill 95.
and the next item of business uh
is uh
I would like to read
the decision that was made
[Music]
no I don't think we're interested
no uh representative sovio to do the
majority report and this is going to be
I'm like
I can do it if no one else does
we're representative Oregon you want to
do The Minority Report sure
okay motion
and is that going to be what would be
the motion on that
I have to pass with a different
Amendment with no Amendment Mr Mr chair
perhaps if representative hargen doesn't
know at the moment what he would like to
have as his Minority Report could you
give him a little time to think about
that
the other item of business is I'd like
to revisit uh Senate Bill 143 if she has
not been sent to the clerk's office yet
and uh I would like uh to make a motion
to reconsider our vote which was ought
seconded by representative Bryce
and
all right just to address it uh we were
short a member last week I've given a
lot of thought to what we didn't end up
with last week and I'm concerned that if
the bill goes forward in its current
form uh that uh it would be unsuccessful
and so I would like to read I did vote
in the affirmative although I'm told by
the clerk's office
that doesn't matter uh you don't have to
have voted on the prevailence scheme
um
it's clear if you wanted
to think
momentarily seriously we want to keep
143 Representatives
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes Square quotes
yes representative Alexander yes
representative Wright yes representative
Mariner yes
representative three yes
representative Kelly yes
representative
yes
representative Smith no
representative you know
representative Oregon no
representative De Lorenzo no
representative Chase no no thank you
representative
no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman gets through the mother in
yeah as as I understand procedurally
what that means is we have to go back
and vote again on the boat that was
taken which was I could pass as amended
at the time
and that was ought to be as we passed
three amendments
which was 1252 which deleted part two of
the bill
1272 which deleted part 7 of the bill
and Amendment 1280 which added an
additional charge to the bill offered by
and
uh
so
what we would be in taking this vote
were
this is a vote on the same boat that we
took before
and I would encourage everybody to vote
is
excuse me
I hate to be the slow one here but could
you just re-explain
what the uh exact result would be with
the yes code and a no vote yeah if if
you uh if you were to vote no then it
would be open to first then we would be
go back to
Senate bill 143.
and it would be open to further
Amendment
if you vote Yes we reaffirming the
decision that we made at the last
session
thank you that's pretty clear thank you
okay okay
no no in order to open it up for further
so let's go just to clarify yourself
Amendment 12 52 1272 1280 are retained
in this by Nova right the closed prior
so the prior amendment made by
representative Smith removing part two
1252 that would remain in effect as
would the motion removing part seven
made by representative Sylvia and the
part made by representative Soviet
adding 1280.
for the former House Bill 133
so if you want to call the roll
um
[Applause]
so
Senate Bill 143
otpa
representative McLean
no
problem no
Court votes no representative Alexander
no representative Christ no
representative learner no representative
green no
representative Kelly no
representative not her no
representative torontier
now
representative Smith
yes
representative Burke yes
representative Oregon yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
mainly yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
Mr chairman
no
I have attended the affirmative 11 in
the negative
so the prior motion about to pass has
amended is defeated it's now open to
further Amendment
I would offer an amendment an amendment
is
13 7.
seconds
seconded by representative Alexander
1378 wait a minute
[Music]
Amendment does four things uh it deals
first of all it deals with part one of
the bill
which we we considered last time pretty
extensively
like the way it's current part one is
currently written is in large part uh
very similar to what we previously
passed in this body
and
uh went to um
was previously passed and was tabled by
at session
this
takes out some things which I certainly
would like to see happen I know most of
us would like to see happen
but uh if what it does is it keeps in I
think what is the most important part
and that is getting kids counsel at the
very initiation of the court process the
delinquency process
and and
doesn't permit them to waive Council
they have to have
circumstances I like that
and
it also deals with the issue of contract
attorneys in that the way contract
attorneys are currently paid if there's
a disincentive for them to become
extensively involved in representing
juveniles and this does away with that
system it allows them to be paid fairly
quick form and will provide them with a
greater Ascent incentive for them to
provide quality representation for
juveniles
and the last thing it does is it sets
forth
requirement that the
uh that
there be standards established
with four
these uh relative to appointment for
juvenile counseling these all came out
of a recommendations that have been made
uh I know it falls short of what many
people would like to have happen and
what they expect but I think we all saw
what happened on the floor in uh
previously and the exception that some
other Representatives took to what was
proposed at a time and I'm concerned
that if we go much further than what is
offered here that but effectively just
going to kill them
the other thing that the uh Amendment
does is it deletes other parts of
Senate bill 143.
that don't delete
uh part
10.
with regard to appeals of the victims
assistance commission and this is kind
of interesting kind of and frankly I um
I'm not sure we got very good testimony
about this but with regard to that there
is a committee which is set up for to
provide to manage the victims assistance
fund
and that commission is set up for the
very purpose of determining what's fair
and appropriate for uh a financial
benefit for remuneration for for victims
but the way this is written it basically
says that if you don't like the outcome
you can go to the attorney general and
the Attorney General can just overrule
the victims assistance Council
that in effect you're making the
attorney general the ultimate decision
maker as to who gets money and if that's
the case there's really no purpose at
all for having the victims and
assistance Commission
doesn't make any sense at all if the
Attorney General can do it anyway and
then you can appeal right now if you
don't like the victims assistance fund
you will just appeal to the Supreme
Court and I just don't think it makes
any sense to do that
with regard to the the other Provisions
it also deletes part nine regard to
relative emergency
medical data and Trauma services and I
think that the testimony we got first of
all I think
my recollection was that Senator Carson
said that she thought that needed to be
amended in any event
but basically
it allows sharing of personal
information
[Music]
that would ordinarily be considered
confidential
and I think it it
it's contrary to what we have considered
in the past is concerns for our
individual privacy
and the it also removes
Section 8 and
which has to do with cyber security and
if you remember the testimony basically
what this was doing was requiring
political subdivisions to report cyber
security incidents
to a cyber integration Center
established by the department of
information technology which I'll I'll
just give concern to me with regard to
the establishment of some type of secret
intelligence agency you know when I hear
those words uh in terms of collecting
information again collecting information
about uh to people and again a concern
again for privacy from my perspective so
long in the short in a men's part one
deletes Parts eight nine and ten and
that's the purpose of the amendment
representative Smith
uh yes thank you very much for that
explanation on Mr chair so am I to
assume that contrary to the very strong
vote
bipartisan vote on the elimination of
part two that we voted on that you have
concluded that you want to keep part two
in the bill
you are included uh inaccurately part we
that Amendment uh that you made
previously remains in effect
and part two is deleted
um Mr chair could you explain how that
could be since what we have done here
is eliminate our final vote
on Senate Bill 143
um uh first we we agreed to reconsider
then we agreed to eliminate that vote
then we went back to the beginning
and going back to the beginning had
section two in it and so I'm not clear
how we can pick and choose and say We'll
honor the removal of two but we won't
honor
the removal of other sections which we
had in fact voted on last time
well this is my understanding and this
is only after uh talking with the clerk
uh and that is
when we we ended the we voted to
reconsider
when you vote to reconsider what you're
doing is voting to reconsider the vote
we took of ought to pass as Amendment
with the Amendments that we had voted on
we voted so we decided we went if we had
voted yes on that
then we would be done today
but uh having voted no on that what that
does is it opens up
the bill for a further Amendment the
Amendments that were already passed
remain in effect so
the Amendments 1252 which was the
amendment for part two the amen the
amendment 1272 with regard to part seven
and the additional part which was added
in Amendment 1280 still remain in effect
well
chair I would never question
your decision I tend to be about and
suspend a person I like to be really
sure but with your
um very strong statement I believe that
I can certainly accept that and when the
calendar comes out and in the fullness
of time the distinguished clerk has the
language
in it
um if perhaps it turns out that
my concern might be justified I
certainly hope that the committee
will step up
to correct that problem
if if it would ease your concern I would
be happy to expand my emotion to include
here my concern is so enormous
that I can't possibly ask you to assume
any of that burden it would be unfair
I I might be totally off base and I'm
perfectly willing to acknowledge that I
just want to make sure that if in the
fullness of time I'm not off base
that there will be an opportunity to
correct the misunderstanding
representative Smith I don't want to
screw up so
if if what I'm more than happy to do is
to uh have a since I the
although we weren't in full agreement we
were in substantial agreement on those
three other amendments I'd be more than
happy to either
it probably isn't fair to include them
in my Amendment because there may be
people that feel differently about that
but I'd be more than happy after we vote
on the amendment that I've just offered
to go back and make a motion that uh we
also approve those three other again
uh we reaffirm our decision on those
three other amendments so well that's
very kind of you Mr chair just as you
very clearly acknowledged that you
thought that your new part one does not
go as far as you would like to see it go
but nonetheless recognizing that there
might be others out there who would
choose to block the entire Bill you're
compromising so too I compromise and I
recognize that elections
um matter and I am in the minority and I
do not want to
um
I do not want to take the chance of
antagonizing any of those who were in
The majority and might consider this the
word I believe that is used is a
dilatory
conversation so I would just abandon
abandon the field
that would go a lot quicker than adding
three more roll call votes on amendments
of the the reason that the yeah the
reason that the clerk ruled the way he
did
um representative Smith is because by
reconsidering we ought to pass the other
amendments were separate votes so we
didn't reconsider the separate boats
that we took on 1252 1272 1280. so by
reconsidering that ought to pass if we
wanted to then get rid of 1252 we would
have to also vote to reconsider 1252 so
that is the reason the 1252 stays in
effect 1272 stays in effect at 1280 stay
in effect in order to remove those we
would have had to have had three
subsequent votes and so that that is why
um the chair was comfortable in making
the the assertion that he made
okay so we're back to the amendment 1378
is there any other yes representative
Burge
foreign
thank you Mr chair
uh I too can can do math and understand
uh a good particle let's discuss as well
as
I understand very well the the chairs
comments on why he was putting forth uh
this amendment
um
given my sense of numbers I basically
want to make some comments about the
overall situation and then the chips
will fall where the chips May I was
hopeful
that this would not
be a team red versus Team blue uh type
of situation but sometimes it happens
it's in the nature of the work that we
do but I think we should forget that
these are not only children we're
talking about our children our neighbors
children but we're talking about
Indigent children and if you want to
know a group that has very little voting
power that's Indigent children I mean
even adult criminals have more of a
voting power than Indigent children
so I'd like to keep that focused
um this bill
I'm likely with
considerable regret to vote for
uh under a feeling that it moves
the uh
the effort for improving our Juvenile
Justice System a smidgen forward
but I want to
um I don't know whether it's easing my
conscience or uh doing part of my
education to
also make it clear here on the record
such as we keep
how much we're not doing here
and I really want to encourage people to
read the report that was done by the
independent Consulting Group because 98
of that is not being followed
and
um it may be true this is all we can get
uh New Hampshire has a way they say of
legislating through the court system
uh today the New Hampshire Supreme Court
just ruled in fact that uh it's improper
to keep uh mental health people people
in mental health emergencies more than
three days without uh due process type
hearing uh remarking that this is
something the legislature could well
have taken care of and well could take
care of but didn't
so the mental health system not for the
first time has had to go to court to get
some basic uh help done and it may be
that the juvenile justice system will
have to go to court to get uh necessary
reforms done but then we run into the
problem of the kids don't have effective
legal representation
so the ability to get to court and the
like uh effectively doesn't work the uh
the amendment in front of us
deletes the requirement
that juveniles be represented during the
entire time the juveniles in the system
the right to counsel and interrogation
for to be put formally in the law has
been removed it can be argued that that
exists anyway as a function of Miranda
but what we have seen in practice is
that it basically doesn't exist uh
because lawyers are not litigating that
issue
um the elimination of fees
for publicly
appointed counsel that's been eliminated
the overall suggestion from a report is
that fees throughout the juvenile system
not be attributed to uh children and
their parents because the kids don't get
access to those because they can't pay
in our state they pay for appeals well
or a portion of appeals there's a reason
we have five appeals in six years when
thousands and thousands of cases
we basically don't have appeals in
juvenile cases in this state
motion work whatever
so we thought we would attempt to do the
smallest part possible which is to say
we'll leave in the cost of appeals we'll
leave in the cost of of out of home
placement we'll leave in the cost to the
parents of counseling we'll just say the
right to a lawyer
should fall on the child and the parents
but that's been deleted too
um the use of counsel for out of home
placements been deleted
so
we're not getting a whole lot of here
and I'm hopeful that maybe in future
years we can and I hope by passing this
it doesn't take the steam out of
energy to do more because uh in this day
we need to do more and I think the
legislature has as much of an obligation
to do that as the court system does
but
I've been reasonably well advised by
people who work on a day-to-day basis
that as our chair has pointed out this
does move the ball forward to some
degree especially in getting counsel uh
sooner
uh and for that reason I intend to vote
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
disappointed
but um because I
I am a you know a big believer in these
kids getting counsel as soon as possible
but
in the interest of taking what I can get
and baby steps to get to the ultimate
goal I will be
um supporting this amendment because I
certainly did not want to take a chance
that it will
um die on the house floor
well and what else
the the only point I'd make and
unfortunately that comes with being 73
years old
having been in the legislature before is
I'm well aware of the fact that
change doesn't usually happen
dramatically here at the legislature
generally happens over time
it happens dramatically in the courts
just like the decision might have been
made today
but it doesn't happen that way usually
in the legislature it happens
incrementally over time and the way I
see this is this is a step forward it
gets the basic thing that we were
looking for in regard to getting
immediate and full representation of
kids and and we have the opportunity to
bring forward the other things in the
certainly look forward to that
I'm disappointed too but I'm also
representing the client yes
representative Sylvia's best
representative developer votes
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes representative
murder yes representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative daughter yes
representative trottier
yes
representative Smith yes
representative Burge yes
representative Oregon
no
representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Langley yes
representative yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
so uh I no further Amendment are there
then
I guess I can make the motion about the
passes second seconded by representative
rights
I hate to hurry
as amended
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Perez yes representative
Berner yes representative yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Representatives
yes
representative Smith
representative Burge yes
representative Horrigan yes
yes
representative Chase yes
representative yes
representative Langley yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman
I haven't yeah
do you want to put it on the consent
calendar
is there any other business we need to
if not uh we have the next Tuesday
hopefully will be our last committee
meeting for this year we'll have the
earring on
Senate Bill 96 and the hearing on the
opposed amendment is
and so be sure to be there
um
Mr chair could you clarify we'll have
the hearing on
the um
on the um the amendment the non-germaine
amendment
right yes that's correct and and then we
will exec
90 cents and will that be
immediately after or are you scheduling
that for the afternoon same day same
morning gonna be immediately thereafter
thank you very much for clarifying it we
any other business today yes
yeah I
uh
I sent out an email asking people uh if
they wanted to participate I guess I
think three responses for people who
indicated that they were interested in a
particular bill
uh so I when several of the retained
bills I think have been addressed
separately and I think they're going to
but I
um I want if
you will indulge me I want to go back to
something that was part of conversation
on an earlier Bill about
um
inappropriate
actions that have happened in other
committees
there have been inappropriate actions
there have been really
not just minor problems but some
shocking problems and I would like to uh
say that I believe the reason that has
not occurred in this committee
is because of
the the
way you have conducted the committee as
you can see you certainly by today you
certainly didn't bend over backwards to
accommodate those of us who are
Democrats but what you did do was behave
consistently in a responsible respectful
way and we are indeed fortunate to have
had that experience rather than the
experience that some of our colleagues
have
um been exposed to in other committees
and for that I would like to thank you
very much well I'd have to say that
first of all you're too kind and you're
but
I think much of it goes to the
composition of the committee and the
people that run this committee because
they have all everybody on the committee
has acted almost everybody has acted uh
respectively and responsibly and I
couldn't ask for a better group of
people to work with and I have to say uh
representative Smith that you've been uh
terrific and when you needed to be
understanding of things that needed to
get done and I really appreciate that as
well
thank you
Mr chair yes as one of the longer
serving continuously on this committee
that has been through a number of chairs
this committee for my turn both
accepts so
okay with that we'll see you next next
thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you